hello and welcome i'm here with miguel
who reviewed ghost recon wildlands and
we're about to test out the new dlc
narco road
um so why don't we get in in it
what's up jake
not much
uh
so you reviewed the game uh what was
your overall thoughts of it for those of
you with winning the prize of the
world's most successful
organization it's inevitable
ask any hustler on the street yeah it
seemed kind of interesting i was doing
something reading about it and it sounds
like you kind of infiltrate these bases
rather or these uh gangs rather than
trying to take them down no one knows
what it is right because i'm going
into this one you're going completely
blind um
when you played it you played mostly
co-op or did you mostly play by yourself
mostly played by myself i'd say this
black cat didn't like the idea of 30
years
started to talk
it tells us that recently
we believe that operating with just this
device and working on if you're playing
with a friend
of name a physical description and a
research at the same time i mean the ai
was impossible for the most part
especially when
what i cannot say is somewhere to start
your hunt
three powerful individuals
even when they weren't in your squad
though right they would still be talking
you'd still hear them even if you had
friends playing right yes maybe they
patched that by now
maybe um gosh what were some of those
lines i got the bike and uh
um but yeah so we're probably going to
play this for a couple hours uh hour or
two
but if you guys have any questions let
us know the dlc is out today for those
of you who have the season pass if you
don't i believe you have to wait till
april 25th
a week from the day that's interesting
they're making me create a character
that is interesting again
well let's make him look ridiculous
or her
we should do it quick though
okay
murphy sparky okay let's do snake
hold the snake look
okay snake with
there's a lot of dust particles flying
around in the background
the dusty area what's your favorite dust
particles in the game
oh man
i don't know
you know what really stands out to me is
the dust particles in dead space
dead space i can see that
i think
i think of uh
maybe it was because of the first game
where i really noticed
dust particles in the air but luigi's
mansion when you shine the flashlight
really you could see little dust
particles i mean not like little dust
particles because the resolution was
high but i'm pretty sure luigi's mansion
had that
let's do random outfit are you sure you
want to randomize yes
okay yeah give her a middle finger shirt
uh someone in the chat is saying that's
actually cocaine floating around
oh okay that makes sense
all right we're gonna see if we can get
into a co-workers
game
maybe make things a little bit more
interesting
especially when i can't hear i probably
can't hear him no we won't be able to
hear him
that's okay though
seriously is that cocaine that can't be
i don't think so i don't know
someone's just standing there blowing
cocaine at the back
just waiting for you to create a
character all right they're creating one
blow
uh if the mics are too low or gameplay
too low let us know and i can adjust
that and once again if you guys have any
questions let us know other than that
i'll be checking the comments and make
sure to
subscribe if you want more on ghost
recon or more on
video games got lots of stuff coming
coming your way
interesting
there's a colorful helicopter you're
undercover in a colorful helicopter
rogue agent
okay
let's see if i can get aaron
i think you joined this game didn't you
or did it not work
oh interesting
be
it doesn't look like he's online
oh well you can try to join us if he
wants
so having reviewed the game what would
you like to like what do you think would
make this game better with this dlc what
do you think they could do to improve
um
well the effort mentioned um
um
you know i got into the ghost recon
series because of all the
hype all the high-tech gadgetry like
especially
um
and this was sort of like a
they kind of scale that back
uh
some of my favorite top classic games
are splinter cell games
uh
the gadgetry so it would have been nice
to have more of that
in this game
yeah
what's your what's your favorite
splinter cell game this is an important
question
uh
i would say
a splinter cell blacklist
really yeah
i liked
blacklist a lot but i had one big issue
with blacklist okay
there was they they changed the voice
actor
right no michael ironside that did suck
let's see okay infiltrator sonic santa
block against your uncovered they
believe you're a rogue agent coming from
a helicopter
parachuting from the most colorful
helicopter the road agent uh failure
gang members gage will unlock boss
missions and vip followers okay
um i turn the mics up
quite a bit because people are having
trouble hearing
us uh so try to speak up a little bit if
you can
talk to eddie
this is just like a
outpost or something
i think this is some kind of gang
compound
everyone looks rather friendly
i'm trying to shoot you
it's a nice pool
in the
can you guys hear miguel now a little
bit better testing testing
unique in new york
um yeah a lot of the chat is saying
chaos theory is the correct answer and
they are right chaos theory is the
correct answer
uh maybe try moving the mic a little bit
closer to you miguel maybe
hey bob jones how's it going tell me how
crazy you are have you heard of
alma
this guy's just doing push-ups all right
all right it sounds like they can hear
you now
sorry guys
[Music]
i love that he can explain all these
directions and i could already just move
on with my mission yeah
i think they want you go off that jump
oh bad
can you you can't customize your cars
really that much in this or your
vehicles uh not that i recall
well
pretty cool looking paint job but
get to a gas station
it's it's moments like this that i'm
reminded like of how awesome uh
rockstars uh smugglers run was
that was uh gta 5 dlc right
uh no it's a standalone game smuggler's
run on playstation
i forgot about that game
okay
let's destroy some cars i wasn't paying
attention do we have to like run them
over or
uh it says destroy them so yeah run them
over
well this is a monster truck yeah i
imagine this should and crush them very
small
did that do it i didn't do it i didn't
do it
that did it
um
also for those of you wondering uh this
is on the ps4 pro
and i believe this is on xbox as well
but you have to
you have to have the season pass in
order to get it now otherwise you have
to wait a week and i think it's fifteen
uh
if if you choose not to buy the season
pass which is 40.
that is what i'm talking about
um and
basically what this includes is it comes
with new vehicles
uh three new gang factions you can
infiltrate 15 story missions i think
what i saw and then new uh new clothing
options and there's actually i think
some splinter cell style clothing
options added
all the nitro will be helpful for
getaways
yeah it is huh a couple more
vehicles
um i believe this dlc does have new air
vehicles as well
yeah this is a supposed to be a stealth
mission
is this i don't know
i don't think this is supposed to be a
stealth mission but we're supposed to
infiltrate the gang at some point you
just run out you ran over an
pleasure
gaming ninja says he loves clothing
options i do too it's nice to be able to
customize your character kind of put
your own personality to it
create something that either like
reflects your own personality or is like
a complete opposite
yeah
and i actually thought the character
customization this wasn't bad
oh yeah there was i think enough options
yeah considering because i remember
division was rather simple
um and this added a bit more a bit more
to it
jake what are some of your favorite
character creations i mean with games
that had character creation
um i mean i love
i love like skyrim and uh
oblivion i had a lot of fun with that
when i was younger
um
fallout as well i don't know i think
bethesda does a really good job of it
and i was like even though the mass
effect games they're kind of subtle with
the character creation well not so much
andromeda but the originals are subtle
with character creation i like
you seem to have a lot of options with
little stuff and it just kept the game
grounded and you could still make your
shepherd look very unique
uh and then tony
hawk pretty much any of the tony hawk
customizations were always a lot of fun
what about you
i think i seem to recall having a good
time with
character customization and dragging a
dragon age inquisition of all games
yeah um
mass effect
can i just
oh all right that seemed late
oh i thought i was supposed to go in the
base okay this is the world today
everybody likes to watch those we have
the good life um
kane the one points out that both uh
the division and this are different
developers um that's true but it seems
like
ubisoft games tend to borrow a lot from
each other
risk everything do all the things they
say you cannot do no one is born
complete you gotta become who you are if
you don't burn out at the end of every
day you are a bomb
yes eddie escavado folks the
self-confessed playboy reality tv star
and extreme sports fanatic now has 70
million followers
i am bigger than people
more talented than amateurs
i've got more wisdom than gandhi
i am 50
more
influential than any human being
ever
for the next thousand years
this guy's got an ego yeah this reminds
me about the the trend in the last like
10 years or so about implementing social
media into the fiction games i think the
first time i experienced it was in um
in dir dirt 2
when
just by winning races you like build up
followers yeah stuff like that and like
forza horizon just kind of like went
yeah i remember before
doing it
um but it's definitely not unusual to uh
it's not unusual to see it in open world
adventure games these days well even uh
persona 5 to an extent right yeah how
you like build up followers as you
steal more people's hearts
okay let's see if i
need to set a waypoint to the next
mission
uh okay
someone is asking what this is being
played on this is a playstation 4 pro
are you allowed to change your outfit at
any time
uh i think we have to go out to the
lobby or the main menu
okay if we do get a chance we should
try because it seems like some people
want to see some of these uh
different costume packs there
that's a good idea
stick around
i will check that out after this mission
that's pretty cool oh [ __ ]
that's it
try using nitro again trying okay
running start here
all right we're going on foot
uh the dlc is not on a new map you are
just playing uh within the original map
but i mean the map is so big i mean do
you really
want more i mean i guess it is nice to
get a change of scenery well it was a it
was a dedicated oh wait there's another
track i'll keep a mental note um
it's not it's super easy to
to find the dlc it's actually in the
main menu as its own selectable option
oh wait now i gotta follow it okay let's
do this yeah let's hop back in this
thing
where are they running from
it's pink
okay
oh yeah another another one of my
criticisms about this game is that it
isn't as off-road off-road friendly as
it should be the terrain seems to imply
yeah i mean i had a much easier time
with just like free roaming in forza
horizon than this game even uh even when
you're riding like a dirt bike if you go
down a hill it like does not
i'm already emotionally prepared to fail
this mission
um because i'm like going off road
got nitro yes that's true
where's your squad too
is it because we're in a we're online i
feel like you should still have your
teammates though right
you know you make a very good point well
this
this game does involve an undercover
agent that's true
people seem to be saying the frame rate
is not that great it seems to be okay on
our end it's not doesn't look like it's
60 or anything like that but it's not
chugging or
uh
or anything like that american system
yeah
destroy sam site with a monster truck
oh you just gotta go in the foot i think
looks like there's some enemies up here
too
right there
it's okay
was the knockout not working it wasn't
working
r3
is r3 just not working it's not working
great
so we just stuck with this guy
can you shoot and no i guess that would
just
r3's hmm
can i plant i need to plant some seafood
this is an issue
i might step out and grab another
controller if we can't get the story i
also can't leave the same site
with him this seems like a glitch
can we reload a save yeah
uh or
let's see can we reload a checkpoint
no um because this game is flawless you
never need to reload a checkpoint
i'm gonna press
every button to make sure
can i change my i can't even change my
weapon
dang i thought it was the controller but
if you can't get off this area then it
has to be a glitch
wow
okay okay
uh let's
i'm sure it auto saves so i'm gonna quit
narco road and then come back in okay
that is probably the best idea we can
also take a look at the new outfits
apparently you don't need to quit and
leave it just in the start menu you can
go to your loadout and adjust it so
oh okay yeah
we can check out outfits
how do you like jake's shirt
he's seeing radiohead tonight
very excited
what's your favorite radiohead song
that is such a tough question
oh man
uh
idea tech probably idiot idiotic okay
um yeah we tried hitting the right stick
but it didn't work
uh
so
yeah let's hope it works now
i i'm going to start a new slot just so
it'll be easier to
winning the prize
check out the character creation you
shouldn't
oh well it's too late now but it sounds
you can just do it in the menu oh yeah
you know what you're right
uh the shirt is backwards because it's
it's a misprint they messed up goop
that's why it's backwards
is it no it's it's how it's supposed to
be okay
uh
so let's check out
some faces
i think it's just the outfits that we
should take a look at yeah okay
oh wait no that's
oh those are one you save
we can just randomize for a while oh no
costumes costumes that's what we want to
see
let's start from the top
cia standard issue infiltration outfit
no i don't think these are new ones it's
probably go down
i don't think we have those unlocked but
we may be able to look at them right
throwing earth
is there see the assassin's creed one
boom all right it's very g.i joe yeah
um
the division all right okay i can see it
all right uh did we do a sponge that one
already
no i don't think so
so i think it's just the ones with that
symbol of the new ones oh okay
the you play ones
oh those are you play ones
uh
i can randomize for a while sure
doesn't seem that random
i just i just pick one let's get into it
okay uh
uh yes this dlc is out today
for people who have the season pass if
you don't have the season pass you have
to wait a week
i believe uh if you do have the gold
edition you already have the season pass
so then yes if you have the gold edition
you should be good to go
i could not i could not release it i
pressed every button
yeah it seemed like a glitch
loading loading
yeah maybe okay
no i wouldn't quit again i just yeah i
just played with this okay i'll be as
quick as i can i was hoping we could
just load from here but i guess not
what do you think of the size of the map
of the main game i found it almost
intimidatingly large it is very big
i hardly saw any of it i played about
i think i played around
eight hours or so and i think i only
visited like three locations or three of
the provinces
um but i do like that i like that
immense sense of freedom
and like you look down there you see a
canyon over there looks cool there's a
city up there
it's cool
it's cool but definitely overwhelming
i'm not entirely sure how long the
campaign for this is
there are three different factions so
i'm assuming
however long it takes you to take down
one in the main game would just be
multiply that by three
no this dlc is not free
and yep seems like you do have to make a
new character when you want to play this
which is weird
yeah there's no
um
i thought this was going to be like this
would have multiplayer but
there doesn't seem to be any multiplayer
options there is multiplayer
with this you're supposed to be able to
do this with your friends
okay
so i can get through this
well good thing we know we don't need to
listen to him you just start talking we
can run away
you know one of the things i pointed out
in my reviews how you could
beat
um you can get to el sueno
by completing slightly like
about half
of the the campaign missions
and uh
if anyone has actually
completed all the campaign missions it
seems like there's a different ending
but that's something i did not see
okay
yeah it seems like if you wanted to do
everything in this game you're looking
at a
pretty long game oh no don't think that
worked 50 minutes i mean 50 hours at
least
because it took me about 30
to
i think also one thing that didn't help
was that
i mean in terms of like selling the
off-road options
in the main game they didn't really
start you in the best area it wasn't
especially off-road friendly especially
when you started with just
bikes
and yeah
it was a there were
quite a few cliffs
and uh
it was just hard to plan
jumps and landings they also had two
betas in that area right so it was when
i finally got the full thing i was like
great i have to
force my way through this area to get to
the new stuff
but right from the beginning of that you
right for venus you can just pretty much
go anywhere right
quite a few options i did not destroy a
single car
dominique in youtube i think it's
dominique asks
is this dlc good uh i don't know we
haven't played much of it yet so far i'm
having fun so far it seems like
it's it seems like more ghost recon with
a little bit more ridiculousness to it
yeah i mean the main game had its uh has
its moments of ridiculousness um
the main game even had like a social
media element to the plot
uh
this doesn't feel out of place
though i definitely understand how it
does feel like
if
if ubisoft ever thought about
um putting this if they ever consider
putting this in the main game i could
understand why they would keep it
separate as dlc i mean yeah it does seem
to have its own flavor
it looks like in the comments they're
saying this is actually
uh is actually single player only which
is weird because i
thought i looked on their ubisoft blog
earlier and it said that this was
this is multiplayer
oh they're letting me into the camp this
time
oops
uh
yay 411 new followers just for that
ran some people over
all right
uh you can access narco road once you
once you've installed it in the main
menu there should be an option that says
narco road click on it and it'll take
you the character creator and then you
can get right in
can you uh take a look at the attack map
some people want to see it zoom out and
see
oh it looks like this is actually a new
area too
cartel activities
oh we can well there's a lot of fast
travel that's unlocked early that's
surprising
um yeah this is this is co-op um
i thought i saw someone say it wasn't
but it seems like everyone else in the
chat is saying no this is definitely
online co-op we even got messages at the
beginning to join co-op games so
yeah for me personally i think it's a
little too
it's it's a little too ridiculous for me
it's not really what i want to do in a
ghost recon game necessarily how about
an open world shooter
i mean did you like did you like just
just cause
i like just cause one and two never got
around to three
um
but i don't know for me it was one of my
problems with actually the main game too
it just seemed weird to be playing a
ghost recon game
like this that's true especially when
like ghost recon has like uh its dna
with the
rainbow six franchise
yeah there's there is a certain like all
business
tactical seriousness about those games
that i did appreciate
and
this is
sort of the opposite yeah
but uh i mean
it seems fun
like especially co-op like i definitely
had a lot of fun playing co-op with
friends
all right let's try this again uh jack
thompson wants to know if or is it it's
jared thompson
wants to know if we can test co-op
possibly uh with a co-worker
um maybe if aaron's online we can try to
invite him but last we checked he wasn't
you know he also had that meeting to go
to oh he had a meeting that's probably
why
uh that's a good question do you know if
turbo's in the main game or just in
steel i don't recall using turbo do you
think they added it though with that
that's a good question if we have time
we could check it out
um yeah i'm not sure
it seems vehicle specific does does it
not or
i have haven't tried anything besides
monster trucks i can yeah i mean i'm
happy to carjack someone
and see if we can use nitro i doubt it
yeah
though then again
i i realized that even if they did add
nitro
to the main game i don't think it would
really adversely affect
it it won't like nerfed
it would have nerfed the game
oh he jumped out good
though there are some escape oh
i failed it because i
oh come on
oh well we'll just focus on getting that
helicopter
uh people do want to see a co-op test
unfortunately i don't know if there's
anyone playing right now that we can
bring him in
at least in the office
yeah it seems like people think it's you
just see the the nitro boosted dlc
okay
reach mission location
and i can just see if i can fast travel
nope
i guess we're gonna find out if there's
nitro in this car
nope doesn't look like it
uh someone is asking would you say this
is better than the division
personally i
i had more fun with this than i did with
the division although i haven't played
that new mode i guess it's not new
anymore but that mode in the division
where it was more
um perma-death
and it was more survival a survival mode
i haven't played enough of the division
to form an opinion
i will defer to jake
whoa hello oh [ __ ] hell
hopefully we're not at a disadvantage
since we don't have a car with nitrous
oh yeah good point well
try not to waste time
yeah someone does mention you can't even
compare this to the vision they are two
very different games despite the fact
they're both uh
third person somewhat tactical shooters
i don't even know if i'd consider either
them tactical shooters but they are
third person shooters they're there's an
element of
what
fail
okay i'm using a monster truck
um but yeah they are they are tough to
compare um
i'd say it's more just preference
is narco road easier than the original
game uh i don't know
does it seem easier so far
uh
those challenges so far with the monster
trucks haven't weren't like especially
difficult
um
i haven't played enough yet
i think we're gonna need to switch to a
car with nitrous when we get there grab
yes
about the soundtrack i got so tired of
this
it it i'm sure there's more than five
songs but it felt like i was listening
to just five songs
are still in bolivia right even though
there's a new map i was just thinking
that i wonder where this is in relation
to the rest of the map
because obviously this is its own little
section but
yeah
i don't know oh wow hello oh wow
[Laughter]
oh that was great
oh
man that needs to be broken out
that was awesome
well we got to walk there again
i forget if there's like a dodge roll
for
situations like that i don't think a
dodger would have saved you
that
truck was coming right at you you're
dead
and the fact that like yeah it was
chasing some sports
cars all over
sorry ally
i'm asking
you uh
this is an interesting question
um
someone on youtube asks how do you think
or how do you what do you think about
the political aspect of this game based
on uh bolivian how people reacted to it
because it seemed like there were some
there were some issues right uh bolivia
wasn't too happy about this game
apparently
well i guess it was uh
ubisoft was
forming its own interpretation of
yeah political climate at the time
um
i don't know
much about
about bolivia these days but yes i mean
i guess i guess any country would be
upset if
um
if if a game portrayed it as being
controlled by
uh drug dealers yeah
yeah i mean i i can see why they'd be
upset but at the same time uh you know
freedom of expression kind of
trumps that to me okay
i remember uh rainbow six vegas two or
rainbow six vegas i remember las vegas
was not happy too i don't know if you
remember reading about that at the time
but they uh
they didn't like that
vegas was being attacked by terrorists
like it's a misrepresentation of las
vegas like yeah it's fiction
uh
dominique is once again asking he says i
have the original game but do you think
i should buy this dlc or not
oh i mean i think that's entirely
dependent on what you thought of it and
if you have friends to play with
i i mean considering how big
ghost recon wildlands is i probably
wouldn't get it unless you have a group
of friends that really want to play it
then that might be worth it in that case
but
i don't know it depends how much you
enjoyed the game oh yeah i mean if
you're on a budget
i mean
based on like my experience playing
uh
the main game there's just so much
content that
or just so much map
all these missions
all the story missions
i mean if you've
exhausted if i mean if you if you've
been able to like
form
parties form squads with your friends on
the main game and you've completed every
uh story cartel mission that probably
speaks to your enthusiasm about the game
and
it on that note it will probably be
worth it to you to
check out this dlc
let's see
cover
oh gosh
i think i made it to the next checkpoint
hi biscuit boy
you make a good point
sj
g money
okay
same site
looks like we did get a checkpoint
shall borrow this
conveniently placed wow what a purple
car what a parking shot i know fit it
right in there
i have huge respect for valley parkers i
can't do what they do
uh people are wondering if there's pvp
in this i don't think there's pvp in
this uh
this dlc
all right
no this dlc isn't blended into the main
game what happens is when you
once you've installed it and you start
up there's an option to play the main
game or you can play narco road
let's start the sam site without
taking anyone hostage
um
um
yeah someone else on youtube kane it
looks like points out that as funny as
this game was there were so many other
great experiences that came out it's
kind of hard to
find the time to even go back to play
play this and and i kind of agree i mean
there's so many so many games
well that's the yeah that's the bitter
sweetness of being very open-minded to
genres is that this the first couple
months of this year we've just been
inundated with quality games
yeah let's see
this way
it's been pretty off-road friendly so
far
yeah it seems like it
you're on my side nope
get out of there
wait it's going why is it going downhill
i have to go up to that sam site okay i
think i got to infiltrate on foot
well i don't think you'll be driving
that car much longer anyway so
headshot
uh someone in the chat said pvp is due
in may so those of you wondering
sounds like we should get pvp soon
it's amazing that it didn't ship with
the game
all right
oh
oh [ __ ]
who said are these guys on not yours not
mine
i love persona
5. i just started on zelda i gave near a
9 out of 10 on gamespot.com
yeah
near persona
zelda horizon zero dawn
so many games
i i kicked off this year with neo
and neo too
you know what's really is really jarring
is you play like 20 hours worth uh 20
hours of near and then you go back to
neo neo is an excellent game
but switching from the pace and the
frame rate
of near and going to the more methodical
movements of neo
it was very jarring
yeah i'm sure
we have a squad now
giving us squad orders we're gonna have
a squad
yeah i thought they were just gonna give
me an ai squad
weird
you know what
oh my god
google agrees with you nir was so good
so you've met goob right
have you signed his playstation i have
signed this playstation sure has you no
no i just
happened well i think i think he's going
to e3
goober going to e3
how did he not see you you just sprinted
in front of him
so i gotta get to that sam site
discreetly
uh it's not happening so far
oh he said [ __ ] balls
that line was made fun of a lot
all right goob
i think
i remember i'll try to bring um
one of like the old shirts during the zd
tv days because uh
the one bit of trivia about me is that i
actually started
at gamespot
back without a cable tv show
in 2000.
i remember watching it
you probably saw some of my segments
i think so
okay
all right very subtle i like the style
seem to be covering ground yeah park
that up top and then just switch to the
mini gun oh and that guy notices you now
i forgot how to switch seats
oh
oh i would
you're screwed get out you're screwed
oh okay we're good
no helicopter escape though
i can't even get into
the gunner precision okay
all right let's get ready ready to go
you're choking
you grabbed him hopefully you can knock
him out
what do we have here what
oh no it's been signed out
all right hold on a sec
uh all right
it should pick up right where we left
off though
okay we're good
oh no
someone's trying to sign in
uh sorry the delay hold on
hold we get this sorted out
suck
okay we're back deal meter sure take the
controller i'm inverted
oh you're inverted all right
i don't even see
okay there you go
can you knock him out
yes
no
or you fall off a cliff and then you let
go of him
don't die though
and it happened again
bear with us for another second here
all right killed
this will i don't know if i can be more
discreet okay i can
i could probably put put a bit more
effort into being discreet here
give it a try here okay
so
well indeed there's a full disclosure
i'll just admit that my wife logged on
at home
it happens she's an accountant and she's
very happy that she's celebrating the
end of tax season and so she's kicking
back today
and
i really need to create an account for
her
probably watching some netflix or does
she play games she plays
uh
she's beaten a number of bioware games
and uh she is way
more into
i think she's like 70 percent done with
horizon zero dawn uh okay
um
someone in twitch is asking are we doing
are you planning on doing a review for
this i don't think we're doing a review
for this but you might know better
um
i don't think so yeah
let's see
nice
looks like there's another guy to the
right of the helicopter i think if you
re-angle
i'm actually playing this like a ghost
recon game
who would have thought
nope
come on
ah
what happened to him they just hide he
was able to like call for backup
come on
wow this guy
can take bullets he's spongy
there it is
drag out
uh
i just hop in that helicopter let's get
out of here
that should tell you where the bird is
it almost doesn't seem like a bad thing
that this
map is smaller because you're not
spending as much time getting from point
a to b true and as we
notice in the map a lot of the fast
travel's already unlocked yeah
it's kind of nice
i am also very glad i could actually
control these helicopters uh
i have the hardest time with vehicles in
battlefield
yeah they battlefield's gotten simpler
over the years
however they still can be tough to
control
just uh
curious what's your most anticipated
game coming out this year it seems like
we've already had so many great games
coming out but there's still games like
prey on the horizon
pray on the horizon
um
you know what i would say
red dead redemption 2
yeah that's mine as well
um i know enough about the series to get
excited even though i actually haven't
beaten the first one oh yeah i saw you
playing that the other day
oh come on
too far
yeah i'm borrowing a nick margaritas
copy
it's
it's very good you're in for a treat
there's a certain like there's a
charming datedness about it it
definitely feels like a game that came
out what
2008 2009 was it 2009 i think yeah or
2010 maybe it was 2010.
um
but yeah i mean you can definitely tell
like there's
i i
i both love and hate the fact that uh
john marston in that game
is kind of just being dragged around
like you kind of don't know why he's
doing some of these things just feels
like you're running errands
for people
um but at the same time he's very aware
of the fact that he is just doing all
these tasks for these people and those
people like don't actually help them and
you have to like
go through all these jump through all
these hoops in order to get them to help
you
that's interesting i mean only a couple
hours in and uh
i'm enjoying it so far i think maybe
because i also like the uh
the gun play and the battles
yeah
that was like the first rockstar game
where i think the gun play finally
clicked for me yeah because
one reason i couldn't get into the into
gta 3 was because specifically because i
was
uh i felt like an errand boy all the
time
yeah which is why i gravitate toward
more
story driven open world games
like brendan mcnair mcnamara's game like
eleanor and uh yeah the getaway
also sleeping dogs
well red dead redemption is definitely
very story driven
however
some of the missions
are very like
do this favor for me and then i'll help
you with this and then you do the
favorite form and they're like just
kidding uh you actually need to do this
as well if you want my help because i
don't have any money oh i'm experiencing
that i'm experiencing that with my first
hour of zelda
oh just barely
i need to figure i got to make sure i
know the throttle of this
seems like a pain no one likes
these kind of missions where you have to
follow them tail them
tailing with a helicopter
i'm gonna do it one more time and uh if
we don't if i fail again i'm just going
to do some open world stuff all right
we'll do uh we'll do it one more time if
it doesn't work we'll do open world
stuff for a little bit and then we'll
probably uh wrap up the stream
maybe check out some other things you
guys might be interested in
oh yeah
duh i should have i should have also
mentioned lost legacy
someone else was hoping last of his part
two would come out this year and don't
think that's gonna happen but i'm very
excited for that
i mean stranger things have happened
it is true
oh
can i can i just sort of like skim the
ground
can you maybe park your helicopter on
the ridge
and look from over there and then you
know cop takes off you leave
no it looks like it wants you to be
above it
come on
just the throttle
oh come on
no you're good you're still you're good
okay just don't fly too high you're
losing signal
a little bit lower
oh you're losing signal
i think you got to fly lower
almost lost them target's too far
uh i don't know games that
i'm hoping we hear about a new splinter
cell game at e3
okay we're doing challenges all right
let's do challenges
okay
what can we do here
electro challenge
client climb that doesn't sound fun
you're just gonna drive a hill up the
mountain
or drive the hill up the mountain she's
gonna drive a car off a mountain
that would be impressive
all right
no i'm not very good andreas
so i'm guessing there's gonna be a car
down there
that we can hop into yeah i see this
with that monster truck
okay
and then just drive up the hill
can i parachute from this slow no
yeah i wouldn't do it
oh okay
oh i'm going now okay yeah that's kind
of cool looks like right when you go
through it just starts it
this is weird like
the the like what you're saying the
terrain like
driving on terrain just doesn't seem
that
good but this whole mini game is based
on you driving on it
wow
but it looks like you
almost made it up to the top a little
bit of a nose dive there
all right
new best
doesn't say anything to shoot for though
there's no medals
i got so i got followers 20.
i don't know if 20s a lot in the scheme
of this well it looked like you have 430
now
okay so great all right we did that
uh looks like there's one involving oh
we gotta fly a plane i'm gonna fail this
but we'll do it anyway
if you guys are watching on youtube make
sure to uh hit subscribe just you can
stay up to date on all the newest videos
we put out i don't think we're gonna do
too much with this dlc apart from this
but we've been doing lots of things on
zelda persona
and plenty more to come especially like
around
the end of this month i mean we're gonna
have mario kart stuff coming soon and
pray
uh early next month so yeah make sure
that subscribe so you can stay informed
you know this day this day night cycle
reminded me about the uh
the photo works we were doing or the the
photos we were making from horizon
oh yeah that photo mode was really cool
in that game yeah especially when you
get like just the time of day
time of day and like focal length yeah
there was there was this one time where
the view i i
jake was passing my desk and i handed
him my control and said make this photo
better
okay
well
let's see here
how far is this drop
i should have parachute jump in
parachute can i parachute from here i
don't know
you might die it's worth it though
is it probably not
oh you're screwed
you're dead
that's really that's a really deep
cavern for a plane
all right we'll give it one more shot
okay
you know i still need to play thief too
i haven't played thief two either i
think i played one in three i beat the
last thief
it was all right oh the the remake one
that was kind of like yeah
it was yeah i didn't play it but it
didn't look very oh we got a drifting
challenge i'll do that all right
let me use the term drive when it comes
to helicopters
uh see muhammad thanks for stopping by
um actually yeah there is new um
there is new call of duty infinite
warfare dlc we're actually going to do a
stream of zombies i believe tomorrow
so make sure to stop by and check that
out if
that is something you guys are
interested in
i i don't follow call of duty all that
much anymore but i do like zombies mode
still
zombies can be fun especially if you
have the right team together
and the patience
if you're in if you're into all things
dark souls and dark souls like dark
souls like games i'll be playing the
sci-fi dark souls inspired game the
surge later this afternoon at three oh
cool
oh i think we need something to drift
with yeah
can i drift with this
we can try
sorry about this brother but i gotta
have the car out
i gotta do six sick drifts
nice
nailed
it that's it
i was only allowed to drift that one
turn
oh come on you fail
i don't know
um all right well before
we wrap up i mean i guess what are your
thoughts on i know we didn't get we only
played about an hour so um
what are your final thoughts on narco
road you know uh i think it
my gut impression is that it achieves
what the uh that open world dlcs are
supposed to achieve would you sort of
give
it sort of like offers its own flavor
um without sort of sacrificing what uh
sacrificing sort of the
the appeal of the main game i would have
liked to have had more opportunities for
you know like some tactical
or not the gameplay
the content matches the value but
um
judging by the the three map segments
uh
there'll probably be a lot of content if
you're the type of person that has
um you know put in already like 40 hours
into the main game
yeah
um i mean i can't speak too much
about it because obviously i've been
playing i've just been watching
um but it doesn't seem like it's for me
but i agree i think if you've been
having a lot of fun with ghost recon
wildlands you'll probably enjoy this too
um but anyway thank you guys so much for
watching and make sure to check back
later today because you will be
streaming
what was that game called the surge the
surge
and tomorrow we will be streaming
ob streaming call of duty zombies mode
the new zombies map so make sure to stop
by and check that out and
make sure to hit that subscribe button
if you're enjoying this it really helps
us out
see you guys see ya
is